[Music]
let's go to joseph man right down the
street in nashville tennessee what's up
joseph
hey dr john it's an honor to talk to you
it's more of an honor to talk to you my
man what's up
so um
i am
considering um
well my wife and i are considering
getting a divorce
i'm sorry ma'am what's up
due to
her alcoholism she's
she's struggled with alcohol ever since
i've known her we've been married for
eight years
my question is i
worry about
[Applause]
if we were to split up
we've got two little kids four and six
and i worry about
primarily their
mental
safety but also a little bit of their
physical safety if i'm not
also there to
monitor
what's going on
if your kids are growing up in the home
of an addict they're going to have some
some significant challenges
that's right
um
then dad leaving yes that will compound
the issues for sure i mean i don't i
don't know there's a lot here and so i
just want to be clear about that
um yes your kids are going to wear a lot
of this stuff
when you say alcoholic what do you what
does that mean
well
early on in the relationship she was
very volatile as more um
the the problems tended to be more bingy
rather than like more of a daily thing
so it was more what happened when she
drank too much you know she would shoot
up but she had a temper anger issues and
i mean there's a litany of of things
before kids that happened i mean
she punched me in the face she threw hot
coffee on me when i was driving
there's been some some stuff that that
stuff has all gone away um and now it's
more
you know just daily
she will uh you know she wakes up very
motivated and
and gets stuff done gets the kids off to
school she's a stay-at-home mom i work
from home
and um
you know midday she'll start drinking
and it's you know it's between a bottle
and two bottles every day of wine okay
and um and by the time you know she is
the kids come home she's uh
just not not her best self i mean she's
a great mom when she's when she is
sober but uh but
not as much when uh when she's not and
and it's starting to
kind of take over
uh impact every aspect of our lives um
you know she blows off plans with
friends she
um
you know she's just not present for the
kids
um she's in in in our bedroom with the
curtains drawn and
lights off
and you know they want to play with her
and she
kind of shoots them away um that's hard
hard-hearted what's she running from
brother
what's she hiding no
i don't know that's what i've been
trying to do i know that there's
something else underneath there and i
just don't know what it is yeah
yeah there's some there's some demons
there man it's heartbreaking yeah
i mean i know that in a in a previous
relationship she was physically abused
one time
um so i'm not sure if that's something
that she's just never dealt with or or
what but you know she didn't really
start drinking until
early 20s so it's not like a childhood
thing that started early and just
dude those things lay dormant for years
and years and years right yeah and the
more as life stress piles up um
alcohol mimics um in a powerful way
alcohol mimics
um
the
it's like a cheap substitute for
relational
chemicals for lack of better terms the
chemicals we get from being in
relationship with other people being
connected to other people
sex does that and um
alcohol does that if you if you look at
the two big challenges with college kids
and we maybe even talked about this
previously on the show but you take 18
year olds from all over the country and
you pull them out of their home systems
and you drop them all in a giant box
you've got a thousand brains screaming
for reconnection and a cheap substitute
for true vulnerable relational
connection is alcohol and
um sex
does she make
what happened now something happened now
that you said i gotta get out of here
what is it
well there was an affair
um
a few months ago there you go um
and that kind of is what started us
you know i forgave her right away and
it's a one-time thing or did she fall
for somebody um it was it was a texting
thing uh it was just a violation of
trust and then um i mean i don't i don't
believe that there was more than that
but there's been a lot of
untruths
and she hasn't really been honest
about anything when confronted with
stuff like that and it's not the first
time that she's broken
violated trust so what makes agreements
in our marriage what makes you think
what makes you think they're gonna take
the kids from you
where does that worry come from oh this
is where they're no i'm not worried
about taking the kids from me um no i'm
i'm more worried about if we were to
share custody 50 50
um her
her time with the kids alone
i'm more worried about their their
safety yeah
and so
i mean
there's been a few instances where i've
been worried about their physical safety
um with her
there's been some times where she's
definitely drank and driven them
not often and less so since i've been
working from home just last year i
started working from home and
i'm able to monitor but there's been
plenty of times where i've had to go
pick up the kids because she's had too
much to drink or
or she's been out with girlfriends
at lunch and it turns into a three-hour
lunch and then
i call her and i'm like where are you at
and she says i'm going to get the kids
and i could tell that she's been
drinking i said you turn around and come
home i'm going to go get them so
if i'm not there to kind of daily
monitor what's going on i'm just worried
about what happens and and i don't know
i don't i don't want to try to take the
kids from her and try to get 100 custody
but i'm also feel like i'm culpable and
responsible for their safety as their
dad and good for you and all right so
listen listen to me carefully okay
yeah i'm gonna tell you something hard
all right this is gonna be hard
um
when you're going down this road that
you're going down right so we've had
infidelity we've had dishonesty we've
got repeated um
we've got breaches in marital trust and
then
you've got
safety issues etc
you have to split this in two ways
way number one that comes first is the
safety of my kids
and your your instinct is right and i
heard you say it at the end there and i
love your heart i don't want to take
these kids from their mother
and what i would say to you is she is
screaming for somebody to please take
these kids from me before i hurt them
and you're her dad their dad that's your
job
okay
and so
the any long term what's this
relationship going to be i can't believe
you did that you stole my kids whatever
all of that is in the name of
i'm keeping my kids safe
think about it this way if a truck was
coming down the road and you saw your
kid in the street and you ran out and
shoved your kid as hard as they could
out of the way of that truck and they
bang their head on the concrete and
scrape their face all up what you did
was right
right that's what we're doing here we're
getting the kids out of the way of a
moving vehicle
the second thing is
is i don't want to read too much into it
because you and i just met but
it sounds like you love this woman and
you're heartbroken about what's happened
and
i would look at custody right now and if
i'm you so this is if i'm you i'm going
for 100 custody because the kids are
gonna get hurt
um they're either gonna get hurt acutely
they're gonna get a car wreck they're
gonna get left somewhere because mom
drank too much or something's gonna
happen and as you go down the divorce
it's gonna get more intense
um
as her body starts to recognize there's
gonna be yet another relational
separation it's gonna get worse
and
then
um
everything is about reconciliation if
she'll do the work to get clean to take
care of herself to deal with some of
this past hurt whatever
it would it's it would mean it would
fill your heart with joy to let these
girls go be connected and present with
her mother but they're gonna get her
cutely i'm sorry i cut myself off or
they're gonna get hurt like you
mentioned
they're gonna be tortured to death
slowly over time by saying hey mom hey
mom hey mom
and they are gonna absorb the message
that whatever else whatever phone she's
holding whatever glass of wine she's
holding whatever friends she's hanging
out with
they matter more than we do
and here's the problem with this
your kids know that part of them is
their mom
and when they start to hate mom or they
start to get frustrated or angry with
mom they start to hate and get
frustrated with parts of themselves
and then what do they do they start
looking for ways to fill that gap
and thus this stuff goes on for
generation after generation after
generation
and it takes a dad takes somebody who
loves these kids like you to say not on
my watch
and so this isn't forever this is i'm
going to keep my kids safe
if you're going to go down this road of
divorce and i'm not here to say i'm
never gonna recommend somebody get
divorced it's a mess
um if you do that your job is to keep
these kids safe and to give your wife a
path back to you
if and when she decides to get healthy
and
how does that sound
yeah i mean that's
that's kind of where we're at
at the moment like literally this week
it's i've told her that
she needs to get treatment and and get
into rehab or else
or else it's over
um what'd she say
she's fighting me on it
okay then she called your bluff
and
i'm telling you
um
if you draw a boundary draw a boundary
i did okay
then you've bought yourself into a
corner appropriately so and now you know
it's next right
right what's next
well if she decides not to go then i'm
i'm
filing what's your what's your uh what's
your time limit
um i'm the kids are with my in-laws
right now and uh i told her i'd give her
until monday when they come back
excellent
good for you
um
do not do this by yourself okay what do
you do for a living
i'm uh in finance okay don't do this by
yourself
it's gonna be tempting to get an
attorney and just file the paperwork and
make this a a spreadsheet transaction
make sure you've got other guys in your
life that you can weep with that you can
call and see you got do you have those
i do yeah i've got two two really close
friends that i'm talking to daily ex is
that so good man and make sure you're
talking to him in person also okay um
make sure you're connecting
if there's any uncertainty in y'all's
conversation any like well if you don't
i'm thinking about
i think one conversation about fairness
and
it sounds like it'd be best to have it
in the morning when she's elusive and
sober and to say here's my deadline and
here's what happens after that deadline
and
be super super clear maybe even put it
in writing and so she can read it where
it says i love you you're the mother of
my our kids you're my been my wife for
almost a decade
i miss you
and you're being haunted by demons and
i'm heartbroken
and i i can't be married to someone who
cheats on me and i can't be
let my kids around somebody's gonna
that they're gonna get hurt right and
an addict is great at deception and
somebody struggling with addiction is
great at turning things around on other
people and hiding and dishonesty
if you write this down in a letter hand
it to her or read it to her and then
leave it with her
she'll be able to go back to it and go
back to it and go back to it and at some
point
she'll look at that thing and say this
man loves me this man really loves our
kids
and it might it just might be
that she gets a glimmer of hope a light
a small little light that
from your letter that says if he loves
me this much
maybe i am worth loving
and that's where healing begins thank
you so much for the call joseph man
we'll be thinking about you let me know
how things go give us a shout back in a
few weeks and let us know how things go
and hopefully your wife comes to you in
the next day or two and says i'm ready
i'm ready to go get help and i'm ready
to turn this thing around we'll be
thinking about you man